the first NPC you meet in the Ring City
DLC is an old pilgrim woman who casts
her gaze over the drag heap she talks
about how she feels like a God looking
over this grand sight of kingdoms and
townships come together she then goes on
to say far below there's a deep dark
hole carved out of a tree from time to
time voices brim in the depths of the
cavity even now muttering the very demon
the Prince Lorien spoke oh I'm sure
horrible sound of an afflicted thing yet
cursing them and if you remember the
demon Prince was said to have been slain
by Prince Lorien eternally scorching his
great sword with fire turns out he
didn't finish the job and to finish it
for him we have to go down the first
thing that you encounter on your way
down are these so-called murk men you
can find and use their hand sight and
their staffs and some are even possessed
by soldier eggs which are said to have a
grave likeness to the human form
and it makes sense that these creatures
of the deep would be down here of course
because human dregs are supposed to sink
to the lowest depths imaginable and the
entire theme this dlc appears to be
descent descent down to that demon
Prince the old woman mentioned and down
to the ring city even beyond that but to
get there you're going to have to go
past these angels who I reckon are going
to be responsible for most of your
deaths in the DLC
in the room I was playing this DLC
everywhere I looked around the room
someone was dying to one of these angels
they're utterly relentless and
especially so in the second section of
this area which unfortunately isn't
shown in the footage that you're seeing
and I think it's the best area the
second section is named earthen peak
confirming theories that the windmills
we saw in the previous trailer were from
there I can also confirm it includes a
poison swamp lothric thieves the
poisonous bug things and a female desert
Pyromancer and of course an angel here
though the angel makes this entire stage
into this huge stealth section it's kind
of like the Dragon God in Demon Souls if
you played that where you have to hide
and you have to wait for its attention
to wander before you can continue so you
run from cover to cover avoiding this
angels glare and hoping it gets
distracted by another enemy and start
shooting them instead really fun there's
never really been a stealth component to
this extent in souls and I didn't like
it until I decided to be really really
patient and then it paid off I
progressed and I figured it out so
interestingly those bolts of light that
the angel is shooting at you if you look
closely it actually disperses into
feathers white feathers that are akin to
those that you see in the lottery royal
bloodline we talked about that in this
video so that's definitely significant
from a law point of view and
additionally and I'm not going to give
too much away here but these angels are
linked to the pilgrims of lond or which
raises some serious lore implications so
it might take you a little while to get
past other than peek and find the first
boss but when you do find it it's
probably going to take you even longer
to meet it because this fight really was
quite tough no one else I could see
could beat it and I only beat it because
I left the DLC a speed ran to Rosario
and I respect my character to get rid of
all its faith points and put it all into
vigor
character was so level 125 which is
really high
this stuff is endgame content for sure
this fight has three phases so first you
find a crimson bat which is a simple
single bat that teaches you the bosses
mood set and then when you get the
Crimson bat to 50% health it summons a
second boss called the demon from below
and the demon from below looks virtually
identical to the crimson bat except that
its fire is more purple than red so the
demon from below will get in your face
and the weak crimson bats will back off
and it mostly spans this ranged
explosion attack that you can see here
so this is phase two and in Phase two
you obviously have a choice of which bat
to kill first
and I think whichever one you kill
affects the third phase of the fight so
if you kill the weakened crimson back
first then the demon from below will
turn into the demon Prince who summons
these floating chaos odds that spam
long-range fireballs at you throughout
the fight however if you kill the full
health demon from below first in Phase
two then the crimson bat will turn into
the demon Prince as well except instead
of the chaos orbs this demon Prince has
the long ranged laser beam you see in
footage here and in my opinion the laser
beam is way easier to deal with than the
orbs it actually leaves him open a
majority of the time and it's a way for
the developers to make face three easier
on you to reward you for killing the
full health demon in Phase two as
opposed to the weakened seen in Phase
two I hope that makes sense but
regardless of what you choose when the
demon Prince is dead you get the soul of
a demon Prince and it reads the demon
Prince after his defeat tellurium
retreated beneath the earth and
lost the memory of the flame that burned
within him marking the end of Damon
Kimes
and further on and find a small Android
ban on and it's just like the little
ringed banner you get from Emma after
you kill board it reads this small
violent were used by enjoys of Great
Lord Gwyn in days of your face the Rings
clip and holds the banner high summon
facilitators of transport for the
pygmies who took the Dark Soul the Great
Lord gifted the ringed City an isolated
place at World's End and he gifted his
beloved youngest daughter promising her
that he would come for her when the day
came so the Dark Soul surely that's what
lies deep below in the ring city and
surely that's our goal and it's also the
goal of others I found the herald Knight
who became these gloated best creatures
according to their weaponry and their
armor they also thought the Dark Soul
but they sank into the dark with the
rest of their Legion their gear becoming
corroded and their forms becoming all
bloated and there's another I can think
of who seeks the Dark Soul Gayle now he
was featured in some of the promotional
material and now we know that's no
coincidence hell you can even summon him
to this boss fight and you know what
else I found in the middle of the
earthen peak swamp I found the loincloth
that looks identical to the one that
Gayle with so somewhere without
undergarment Gayle is travelling towards
the Dark Soul with a
so that's pretty significant from a law
point of view and I'm not going to talk
about that here I'm going to talk about
it in my notes that are below this video
in the description because there is a
ton of stuff that I have intentionally
left out of this video and you can read
all those notes in the description
instead I'll explain why in a minute but
in those notes you can read about how I
met the character lap who is an amnesiac
Knight who has forgotten who he is and
he's looking for the purging monument to
cure his hollowing I wrote down all of
his dialogue and I wrote down all of the
dialogue for the pilgrim lady at the
start of the DLC thank god I can touch
type but so hard to keep up there's also
a list of all the weapons I found
including a pyromancy melee attack that
slapped people around with a giant fan
of fire I've also included the secret to
killing the angels so spoiler alert and
I've also written down what I think that
could mean for the story and I've
written down a lot more and I would talk
about this stuff but I hate making
videos that just show the same footage
over and over again and this is the only
footage I have and this stuff is really
interesting and I don't really want to
talk about it behind this same loop that
you've been watching for like what ten
minutes now so I think this is the best
way to get it across to you but um these
are the kind of notes I make available
for beacon patrons but today I'm going
to share it with everyone because I need
to share this early access I really want
to although so many spoilers here
honestly I think there's too many
spoilers at this point in my notes so be
careful when you read them you should
know what you're getting into
oh and these next bits of footage want
in the section I was able to play so
first a night with a brand upon his
chest has this sword move set that
reminds me of the soul of cinder and
Gwynn's combo and he has an arch Dragon
shield which I think implies that these
Knights would have been around for the
war against the Dragons
so this city must be really old if
that's true
next is this long bridge sequence with
this firing squad curved knife that look
a little bit like they have the rune
Sentinel helm from dr. old - and there's
the gray judicata giant in the
background who is possibly summoning
them the police leave like this stuff
leave interesting took a while to get it
over and down and thank you for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]